hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich möchte heute mal wieder etwas
saisonales machen es ist ja gerade
wieder zwetschgen und pflaumen zeit und
deswegen gibt es von mir einen leckeren
zwetschgenkuchen mit hefeteig boden mit
fruchtiger füllung und knusprigen
haferflocken streuseln und ich möchte
jetzt zuerst mal ein hefeteig zubereiten
und samstags die zutaten
ich brauch 250 gramm mehl einen halben
würfel hefe zwei esslöffel wasser 40
gramm zucker etwa 100 milliliter mädels
einen halben teelöffel salz 1 41 gramm
verlassene butter und zu ernst fühle ich
jetzt das wasser zur hefe mit der zug
kann ich nämlich die hämischen auflösen
dann fühle ich das schon mal in die mix
schüsseln in die rührschüssel ich mach
das jetzt mit der küchenmaschine aber
ihr könnt auch den teig mit der hand
verkneten müsste halt nur lange genug
nähten
da kommt jetzt der zucker mit dazu und
bereiten teil vom mail
so etwa die hälfte etwas milch noch
nicht komplett
ich habe jetzt so ungefähr die hälfte
drin und das ei und es lasse ich jetzt
erstmal ganz gut verkneten
dann gebe ich jetzt auch das restliche
mehl mit dazu das salz und auch die
butter butter kommt immer zum schluss
mit rein kann nämlich die hefe besser
aufgehen dann schließt sich das fett
nicht um die hefezellen jetzt noch mal
schön verschmähten und eventuell brauche
ich jetzt noch etwas mit deswegen halte
ich es schön bereit und wenn der teig
richtig schön weich ist und geschmeidig
ist lasse ich ihn noch mal etwa fünf bis
zehn minuten kneten
der teig ist fertig wenn er sich vom
schlüssel rand löst und dann so eine
kugel bildet jetzt vorm ich daraus auch
eine schöne kugel also immer so von
außen nach innen haben eine glatte
oberfläche gebe ich etwas medien die
schlüssel rein und muss den teig erstmal
aufgehen lassen noch mit bisschen mehl
bedecken dauer nicht so aus und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt schon mal
die streusel herstellen und für die
streusel brauche ich nur die zutaten die
stehen hier
und zwar habe ich hier 100 km/h flocken
100 gramm zucker 75 gramm butter und ich
brauche etwas zimt und das mache ich
jetzt alles ganz schnell geht hier oben
in den aber ihr könnt es natürlich auch
mit den händen verkneten fix ist auch
gleich nicht so lange
denn ich möchte es nicht dass die
haferflocken dann fein gemahlen werden
ich möchte einfach nur dass es alles
vermischt wird und deswegen muss ich es
erstmal butter und zucker mit einem
halben teelöffel zimt gut bei der cd ist
im mittelmeer sind aber das macht nichts
kurz vermischen
und jetzt gebe ich noch die haferflocken
mit dazu die werden jetzt ganz kurz nur
noch eingemischt
das reicht auch schon und die fülle ich
jetzt ganz kurz um und stellte schnell
kalt
während der teig jetzt noch aufgeht und
die streusel noch kühl stehen kann ich
jetzt schon mal die füllung zu bereiten
und für die füllung brauche ich pflaumen
oder zwetschgen ich habe jetzt hier
etwas mehr als ein kilo bereits entstand
also das entspannte gewicht sind dann
eben wissen mehr als ein kilo
dann habe ich hier 200 milliliter saft
da habe ich ein apfel saftig nehme etwas
vanille extrakt 40 gramm zucker 45 g
speisestärke die schale einer zitrone
und später brauche ich noch 50 gramm
gehackte mandeln zuerst stelle ich jetzt
mal so eine art pudding her aber ich
lasse es jetzt nicht auf kochen
deswegen gebe ich es einfach mal die
zutaten anzapfen
speisestärke und zucker in einem topf
verrührt es kurz miteinander und
schaltet auf mittlere stufe damit eben
nicht auf koch also sonst nur kurz
auflösen
denn kochen darf man später im backofen
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt
hier schon mal die zwetschgen klein
schneiden
ich schneide sie jetzt in würfel in 1 cm
große würfel
das mache ich jetzt hier kurz dem
alligator aber es geht natürlich auch
mit einem messer
jetzt gebe ich die zwölf stücke hier mit
rein zu dieser saft mischung
frühere ich das kurz miteinander und das
werde ich jetzt hier doch einmal ganz
kurz aufkochen dann geht's auch vom
volumen her so ein bisschen runter und
ich gehe da jetzt noch erstmal die
zitronenschale mit dazu die finde ich
fast ganz super zudem swatch group gibt
ein tolles aroma aber ihr wisst ohne
kommt bei mir auch mit rein als pasta
dollar
die planung dürften jetzt einmal
aufkochen und ich kann jetzt schon mal
den hefeteig ausrollen besser
aufgegangen
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich hier
schon mal die mandelblättchen in die
pfanne geben und sie einfach so ein
bisschen anrösten fürs aroma
und ich habe hier schon mal eine form
vorbereitet und zwar ist es wieder so
eine tat form mit hebe boden mit löchern
damit eben schön knusprig wird und sie
bespricht jetzt einmal ganz kurz mit
bach trends prey und ich hab das jetzt
auch direkt auch so ein backpapier
gesetzt weil durch die löcher einfach so
ein bisschen auch fett aus tropfen kann
meint amazon sechzehntel weniger teig
auch mehr und ich rolle diesen teig
jetzt etwa 35 cm groß aus denn die form
hat nämlich einen durchmesser von 30
zentimetern
ich brauche es aber für den guten
die man diese mit etwas an gebräunt und
ich hole mir jetzt hier diesen teig auf
mein aus hollstadt dann kann die matte
nämlich direkt weg und dann kann ich
denn über diese form darüber legen
jetzt kann man hier diesen run zu schön
hochziehen und auch an drücken
dann gebe ich jetzt direkt die mandel
blätter auf den teig und verteilt sie
kurz die sorgen dann so ein bisschen für
den brunch im kuchen so richtig lecker
und da kommt jetzt noch diese füllung
drauf
und jetzt gebe ich zum schluss macht die
kalten streusel mit drauf und dann darf
der kuchen nehme ich erst mal bei 175
grad celsius im backofen bonn und neetze
für ungefähr 35 minuten backen
wenn er fertig ist lasse ich ihn erst
abkühlen und dann zeige ich euch das
endergebnis
der kuchen ist jetzt fast abgekühlt also
jetzt ist dann noch so ein bisschen
lauwarm
aber ich setze ihn jetzt schon mal auf
nico platte ich habe jetzt hier den
vorteil mit diesem hebel boden muss ich
nur jetzt vorsichtig den rand so ein
bisschen lösen
die eine hand ist unten und die andere
löst den rand dann geht es auch echt
super gut
setzt sich das hier auch eine platte
aber ich möchte mir jetzt diese form
nicht zerkratzen deswegen nämlich der
unterwelt und da geht man einfach
mitzunehmen toten reh darunter
gleich die platte wegnehmen und die
torte schön wieder hier draußen und
jetzt können dass sie entweder so lassen
oder einen zuckerguss aus zitrone und
puderzucker machen finde ich ganz lecker
am heute möchte ich einfach so ein
bisschen süden steht darauf haben dass
sich dieser puderzucker dennig schmilzt
und ich finde es sieht so richtig heraus
wie aus einem oma kochbuch und richtiges
rezept ich finde einfach sagen ja auf
jeden fall zum servieren in schuss
zahlen also von klecks sahne mit drauf
geschlagene sahne einmal anschneiden
sahne und ein café als es könnte sein
dass jetzt noch ein bisschen zu warm ist
zum anschneiden
genau weil der pudding darin muss jetzt
erst mal wieder ein bisschen kalt werden
also jetzt läuft alles so ein bisschen
weg
aber ich glaube du musst schon jetzt
auch warm nicht probieren oder nicht
warm dann warten wir noch kurz
bitterkalt ist auf jeden fall haben wir
jetzt unten diesen schönen hefeteig dann
die fruchtige pudding zimt und the edge
die mischung nicht sind der zimt drin
also auf jeden fall aber unten diesen
schönen hefeteig dann diese fruchtige
zwetschken mischung mit pudding also mit
dem mit der speisestärke janine pudding
und dann diese zimt haferflocken
streusel und wir lassen es ist doch
schön abkühlen
und wenn ihr das nachmachen wollt geht
einfach auf salehs blog.de da gibt's
noch mal das genaue rezept und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen
bis dahin tschüss
ich gebe es mir ab es brauche neues
verständigung
ok